well an extra two billion dollars is now
one step closer to Landing in the CCSD
budget The Proposal could drastically
increase funding for departments like
English Learners at-risk students and
special ed eight news now education
reporter Joshua peguero breaks down how
the budget cleared a major hurdle today
I just want to remind everybody that our
job is to fund education your unions and
your collective bargaining is what does
the rest of it we have put a 26 percent
increase in defunding of Education a 2.3
billion dollar piece and so we have done
our part in order to tackle other
legislative priorities by law the state
must pass an education budget earlier
this year Governor Joe Lombardo made it
a priority to increase school funding
and it seems poised to happen
assemblywoman Danielle Monroe Moreno
says superintendents and districts need
to put these funds directly into the
hands of teachers and kids I would
encourage them to look at that
additional funding and put that money
into the classrooms into the resources
that our Educators needs into their
paychecks the 26 increase in funding
comes as Nevada ranks near the bottom of
States when it comes to per pupil
funding a survey issued last week ranked
Nevada 49th when it came to student
performance it took into account reading
and math test scores High School
graduation and Dropout rates and act and
SAT scores I don't disagree with any of
this but I do think we need some
guardrails we need to make sure that
we're not just talking about money that
we're talking about outcomes and
performance and making sure these
programs work and lift our children up
because in the end it's about education
let's take a closer look at those
numbers now currently per pupil CCSD
gets a little bit more than seven
thousand dollars however that could
increase to over nine thousand dollars
the new budget now goes before the
Senate and the assembly for a vote and
then if it passes it's on to the
governor's desk for his signature